a massive debate breaks out about
pornography among conservatives
impeachment plows ahead and the
Inspector General of the Justice
Department shreds the FBI I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn dot-com / Ben ok
so there is this don't worry I'm against
all the news I'm gonna to impeachment
I'm gonna get to the Inspector General
of the DOJ who is who is attacking the
FBI we're gonna get to the 2020 rights
like all of it we'll get to it but there
is this fascinating and I think
important debate that's now happening
among conservatives over pornography
which is weird right it's weird because
pretty much all conservatives agree
pornography bad right if you are a moral
human being I think that you agree
pornography is not an inherent good for
human beings they're a good scientific
studies showing the effect of
pornography on the human brain does have
a drug-like effect on the human brain
because there is a release of serotonin
because it does prompt certain brain
activity that is addictive in nature
pornography is indeed a major addiction
problem particularly for young men it is
enervating for the sex life it is
degrading to women I wrote an entire
book on pornography is my second book
all the way back in 2005 about the evils
of pornography in American society so I
am very much on board with the idea that
pornography isn't evil and that poor and
that consuming pornography is a moral
bad but there's a big debate that is
broken out among conservatives about how
involved the government should be in
regulating pornography and the debate
isn't really over pornography the debate
is really over what the role of
government ought to be generally and
it's turned into this broader debate
conservatives versus libertarians in
which conservatives basically argue now
many conservatives are arguing that the
government's ought to be engaged in
promoting what they call the common good
and libertarians are arguing the
government needs to completely stay out
of this particular business now I've
been saying for pretty much my entire
career then when it comes to matters
governmental I tend toward
libertarianism and when it comes to
matters cultural I'm very conservative
because I believe that the founders
predicated the notion of a small
government of a government that is there
to protect your rights
on the idea of a moral and religious
people right this is John Adams his
famous line that this government
only constructed for moral and religious
people otherwise the the dark side of
human nature would tear through the
bonds of the Constitution like a whale
through the cords vennett and so that
the entire presupposition of the
founders that you would have a moral and
religious people and if you read Alexis
de Tocqueville in democracy in America
he talks about how that social framework
already existed that social framework
long preceded the founding of the United
States how Americans were apt to join
associations how Americans were apt to
be a member of churches how Americans
were broadly religious and personally
liberal in terms of how they approached
economics and regulations on other
people because when you have a baseline
level of social fabric and trust in
people then you don't feel the need to
regulate them as much and so you need
one to support the other in other words
you do need a moral and religious fabric
in the United States in order to support
a small government well one of the
things that has happened over the past
50 years is the complete fraying of that
social fabric the morality and the
religiousness of the American people
obviously when it comes to matter sexual
but also in matters like drug use and
matters like family formation and all of
these things have declined pretty
markedly and so this has led to a really
fascinating debate among conservatives
what's the first step here do you
restore the culture or do you simply do
what the left would do and try and grab
the commanding heights of government
then cram down from above and I am
firmly on the side of you have to grab
the culture first and if you want to
work on the culture you require the
government to remain small because the
fact is that you are not operating in a
vacuum you are not operating in a world
where you can simply grab the auspices
of government and teach the people the
right thing to do nor by the way do I
think that it is moral to use the force
of government to teach people the right
thing to do because I think that that
completely overrules the idea of a
representative government if the people
don't believe a thing and you're gonna
use the government in order to cram down
the thing that is inherently immoral
whether you're doing that on the left or
whether you're doing that on the right
now even if the government is doing
something I think is moral and they are
cramming it down on the people that is
not what the government is designed to
do because then the government is
basically dictating to the people what a
cadre of people at the top think is
right now I may believe that there is an
objective moral good I do believe that
but I also don't believe that I get to
be the dictator over people I think that
completely defeats
a notion of representative government
you may as well go back to the
philosopher kings of Aristotle and Plato
really Plato so where exactly is the
limiting principle when it comes to the
involvement of government in promoting
quote-unquote justice and the common
good and you're seeing a lot of folks
people who write for me right people who
write over here at daily wire and this
is why I think it's an interesting and
fascinating and necessary debate that's
breaking out among conservatives because
it doesn't only have social implications
and issues like pornography I think the
argument starts at pornography but very
quickly it ends up in the realm of
economics where you have people like
Tucker Carlson suggesting that it's the
job of the government to promote the
common good economically speaking which
is starting to sound indistinguishable
from Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
in a lot of ways and once you get to a
common good government what you're
really talking about is a select few
people who know best for the rest of us
how exactly we ought to live our lives
now that sounds good if the select few
is you but if there's anybody else it
doesn't sound so good in other words
we're all fighting over one government
gun the bigger the government gun is the
more it matters who controls it
the smaller the government gun is the
lesson matters who controls it and so
what I have been promoting my entire
career is that the government gun should
be particularly small when you're
talking at the federal level I'm gonna
get into the specifics of this because
again I think that the argument is being
made about pornography but really the
argument isn't about pornography it's
about economics it's about the role of
government in life generally and it is
an argument between conservatives with
regard to government meaning they want
to promote conservative goals using the
government and libertarians who say no
you can't touch the government this way
even libertarians who have conservative
moral values like me who believe that
you have to rebuild that social fabric
outside of government the sort of James
Madison view that if government gets
involved with religion it ends up
actually hurting religion rather than
helping religion I'll get to all of that
in just one moment first let us talk
about how you are going to improve your
smile for the holiday so the holidays
are fast approaching and your teeth are
out of place because when you were a
teenager one of the things that you did
is you flushed your retainer down the
toilet I know we all did it it's been
gone you haven't worn your retainer in
20 years after you got those braces off
the orthodontist is like you're going to
wear those every night you're like yeah
I am and then three days later you
forgot them in your in your lunch at
school and they were gone forever and
you never wore them again and now you
have teeth like a like a World War one
ear uh British soldier and now you're
looking around you like I got to fix
these teeth this is where I can
and you don't want to have those
horrible wire braces what you really
want is candle liners they can help
straighten your teeth faster and cheaper
and traditional wire braces treatment
takes just six months on average and
cost sixty-five percent less an
experienced orthodontist licensed in
your state creates a custom treatment
plan then they show you a 3d preview so
you can see how your teeth will look
after you're done candids aligners are
comfortable removable completely
invisible there's no hassle of going to
an orthodontist office canid shifts your
aligners directly to you plus in the
season of giving candidate is donating
twenty five bucks with each aligner
purchased to smile trained they bring
safe 100% free cleft lip and palate
treatments kids around the globe give
yourself the gift of candid head on over
to candid co.com Shapiro's use coach
Shapiro to get seventy five dollars off
that is canon co comm slash up hero code
Shapiro for seventy five bucks off Canon
co.com slash Shapiro and use that promo
code Shapiro ok so Jane Costin over at
Vox actually has a pretty good article
on the debate that has broken out among
conservatives over pornography and the
regulation thereof today she says social
conservatives are ready to launch a new
national war on pornography it's been
nearly 50 years since the Nixon
administration's war on porn more than
two decades since the signing of the
Communications Decency Act the first
major federal effort to regulate online
pornography but pornography continues to
be a target of Republicans at the state
level in addition the 2016 Republican
party platform stated that pornography
with its harmful effects especially on
children has become a public health
crisis that is destroying the lives of
millions by the way I agree with every
word of that I do that I do believe that
pornography is a public health crisis
that affects children in
disproportionate ways if you talk to
teenage boys it is really screwing them
up in serious serious ways which is why
I do believe in regulation of the
distribution of pornography to people
under 18 once you're an adult that
changes
hey this fall Republican members of
Congress asked the Department of Justice
to declare prosecution of obscene
pornography at criminal justice priority
conservative commentators also argue
that government power can and should put
a stop to pornography for the benefit of
the so-called common good by doing so
social conservatives argue that they can
alter American culture itself okay and
this is the part where you start to
shade over from the argument about
pornography into the organ about the
role of government generally is
government there to quote unquote
promote the common good or is government
there to protect rights that pre-existed
government is particularly the federal
level his government
to protect rights that pre-exists
government and it does not have the
ability to step into other areas no
matter how morally you think the
government is acting when it comes to
individuals now again I'm gonna make a
distinction between federal and local
because in local government you have a
lot more room to move in terms of what
the government can regulate why because
people can move and once once the
federal government take something over
then nobody has a choice anymore
right this is why I famously suggested
that if beta or orc got control of the
auspices of government of the federal
government and started to outlaw
religious practice basically you'd have
a civil war in the country and if you go
back and listen to the podcast where I
talked about this I said okay if it's
outlawed in California I moved to Texas
if saladin Texas I moved to Idaho and if
it's outlawed across the United States
then you have a civil war right this is
this is why there's a difference between
the federal government and local
governments there's more homogeneity and
local governments there's more
generalized agreement and local
government and so you can more easily
agree on how to regulate the public
spaces okay so Terry Schilling executive
director of the American principles
project a conservative think-tank argued
in October in the Catholic magazine
first things that efforts to regulate
pornography are part of a broader
phenomenon he said in our time a new
conservatism is being born one less
interested in managing our nation's
decline than in using political power to
promote virtue public morality and the
common good and these are the kinds of
words that actually put a show up my
spine when you're talking about the
federal government because the left uses
exactly that same sort of language of
course that the gut the government is
going to promote virtue how by banning
churches the government is going to
promote public morality how with hate
speech laws the government is going to
promote the common good how by
withdrawing excessive amounts of wealth
from the system and then redistributing
them or regulating business into the
ground right as soon as the government
is in the business of promoting the
common good
the obvious question becomes okay and
who defines the common good now
conservatives will say well the left's
been doing this all along why shouldn't
we do it and the answer is because the
left shouldn't be doing it and even if
you agreed with what the left was doing
the Left shouldn't be doing it this is
not the role of government the founders
did not set up the government in order
to quote unquote inculcate virtue to
promote virtue or the common good the
idea was that the the the Lockean idea
behind the founding of the United States
is that there were rights that per
individual rights that pre-existed
government and
government was enshrined at the federal
level to protect those rights and that
that's why the government was made weak
that's why the government has checks and
balances if it were just about promoting
the quote/unquote common good why not
have a monarchy why not have an
aristocracy that decides why not have
the Supreme Court simply decide all
social policy in the United States
Schilling says conservatives need to
overcome their fear of governing the
nation that elected them well okay so
let's be clear about one thing the same
nation that quote-unquote elected
conservatives also elected Barack Obama
in an entirely Democratic Congress in
2008 so what Barack Obama had been
justified in using the government the
way that he did because obviously he's
governing the way that they asked him to
and the answer of course is no because
the federal government was designed not
to do these things
Jane Carson rights in doing so social
conservatives are facing opposition from
libertarians as well as fellow
conservatives they argue that efforts to
ban or otherwise tighten regulations on
pornography is the kind of overreach
they've long stood against so here's the
thing the reason I keep saying that
pornography is a weird place to make
this stand is because I think that on a
libertarian ground there are plenty of
places you can regulate pornography so
let me take a couple of quick examples
it should be criminal to exploit women
and it is right sexual trafficking and
women that is criminal it should be
criminal to distribute pornography to
minors and it is it should be left to
local principalities to determine how
the public square' works if you if you
live in a town and your town decides
that it's going to be a porn free town
that's their prerogative there's no
fundamental right that is invaded there
the Contra the the hardcore libertarians
who say that pornography is protected by
the First Amendment
the founders would have been shocked to
discover that wood carvings of naked
ladies would it would have been
protected by the First Amendment that's
just nonsense it's not true okay the
First Amendment was designed to protect
political speech it was not designed to
protect obscenity the Supreme Court has
recognized as much that's not just me
that's the entire history of the United
States okay so yes certain types of
criminality of pornography totally
acceptable on a libertarian basis
because again libertarians do
acknowledge that there are such things
as externalities right I am not allowed
to pour toxic sludge into a river
upstream of you and I shouldn't be
allowed to post a giant billboard
outside of my business in the public
square that has a naked lady on it right
regulation of that not at the federal
level again I don't think the federal
government has the power to do that
but the local government not only am i
fine with that I agree with it now I'd
prefer to live in a community that did
that okay but that's not what the
argument is what you're seeing is
considered so-called conservatives and
that they're conservative but they're
not conservative with regards to
conserving the original founding purpose
of government they would consider
themselves Burkean conservatives
preserving tradition through use of
government I think even that is a
mystery to Viet Minh Burke but that's
that's how they characterize themselves
this sort of Russell Kirk II and we're
preserving tradition by use of
government and and shying away from
using the government to protect
tradition is a betrayal of the purpose
of government that really is not in line
with founding thought in in very serious
ways but with that said conservatives
who are making the case that the
government ought to be promoting the
common good by for example regulating
the use of pornography inside your own
house or the production of pornography
among consenting adults like there you
start to get into the territory of the
government doing what's best for you and
I am not in the business of the
reshaping you as an individual moral
human being that's for your church
that's for your family that's for your
social fabric that is not for the
government to do and by the way I feel
this way consistently across the board
it's not for the government to do on an
economic level the government doesn't
get to step into consensual economic
exchanges it's not for the government to
do even with regard to things I don't
like right I've said before that I think
that the government's overreach in the
Civil Rights Act is not with anything
regard to state action I think the
government had a perfect right and
perfect ability and perfect moral duty
to step in and stop States from
enshrining segregation but I have
serious problems with the aspects of the
Civil Rights Act that dictate that
private businesses ought to be
prosecuted for discrimination why
because they're private businesses and
you have a right to do wrong in the
United States things that are bad you
have a right to do and then presumably
you go out of business I mean that would
be the hope the hope is that you then go
out of business if you discriminate for
example it will get to more of this in
just a second because it is a deepen and
fascinating debate first let us talk
about your life insurance okay so it's
nearing the end of the year you got a
to-do list and now you're trying to go
through that to-do list perhaps on that
to-do list his life insurance and you
keep putting it off because who wants to
think about in case I die very
depressing going into the end of the
year good news you can get it done
fast you can get it done quickly all you
have to do is head on over to policy
genius comm policy genius will find you
the right life insurance at the best
price and do all the work to help you
get covered you just need to get in
touch with them policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers to find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy it can also help you find the right
home and auto insurance disability
insurance so if you need life insurance
but you aren't sure where to start
start at policy genius calm it only
takes a few minutes to find the right
life insurance policy apply and cross
another thing off that to-do lists
policy genius calm when it comes to life
insurance it is indeed
wonderful to get it right n cross that
thing off your list you don't have to
think about your impending doom anymore
policy genius calm go check it out right
now okay so there are so many questions
that are implicated in this whole thing
one is the role of government there's a
big debate now between quote unquote
common good conservatism and
conservatism that protects fundamental
rights and that debate has serious
consequences as I say for a wide variety
of human activities I'm firmly on the
side of government is not there to
promote the quote unquote
common good other than regulating the
public space which again somebody's
gonna regulate the public space but
people who are trying to outlaw
pornography are also trying to regulate
the private space and this is where you
start to get into very very dicey
territory and again I don't even think
you need to do this to regulate
pornography right again I think the
pornography is not a fundamental right
so it's not protected by the
Constitution
but let's but let's just talk about if
it were right if it were a fundamental
right to to have pornography in your
house for example
well then presumably the government
would have no role in going in there and
common good conservatives would say no
no they do they have a role to go in
there to teach the American people
things right we got to teach the
American people and so this is broken
down into libertarian versus
conservative lines Reason magazine
editor-in-chief Katherine mangu Ward
told Jane Costin what you're seeing now
is this rise of a much more
authoritarian and state oriented variant
of conservatism and it says you know
what actually nevermind let's take away
the bad choices let's make some bad
choices illegal this has long been a
characteristic of the American Left
Matt Walsh she writes rust over at Haley
where he says we say we're
servitors what the hell are we trying to
conserve maybe that question really is
the central question of this whole
debate okay and this goes to a deeper
question and that is if you're trying to
conserve conservative principles moral
principles free markets both of all of
these things if you're trying to
conserve all of this what is the best
way to conserve all of this is the best
way with a big intrusive government that
is able to overrule the will of the
people on social issues where you don't
like what people are doing but then you
can turn that gun over to the bad guys
in terms of morality you don't like
every four years or so and then they do
it back to you plus they take over the
economy or is the government's a blunt
force instruments is the government
incapable of a of separating these
issues out I'm of the belief that the
government is not capable of separating
these issues out and what and
furthermore I don't think that the
government is is in the moral right when
it crams down moral values that the
American people have not accepted this
is why again localism is a great thing
subsidiarity localism it's a wonderful
wonderful thing because you get local
governments where more people agree and
there you don't have to worry so much
about cramming down on people who
disagree because of course they are all
local and they can leave okay so so this
has become a big issue in the area of
economics as well what you're seeing is
a crossover between the so-called common
good conservatives on pornography and
common good conservatives on economics
who say that it's time to regulate the
free market economy make the market work
for us make the market the government
has the ability and and should have the
strength to take the markets and put
them under heal and make sure that they
are working for the quote unquote
American people now that sort of
language has long been the area of the
left so how do you separate off the role
of government in promoting cultural
conservatism from the government role in
promoting economic conservatism and the
answer is it's very difficult to do so
and I think frankly impossible in this
day and age so what exactly is the is
the baseline argument underneath all of
this this is the real key is politics
upstream of culture or as politics
downstream of culture so one of my
mentors Andrew Breitbart was famous for
saying that politics is downstream of
culture in other words the country
changes culturally and then the law
changes to reflect the country's culture
and this is obviously true it is
obviously
hey now the law can help accelerate
cultural shifts that are already taking
place right the but the law cannot
provide a final Brewer against a culture
that has left it right if the law is
promoting something that the people do
not believe in then the law eventually
becomes non enforced and then just dies
that's what happened for example with
regard to sodomy laws to take an example
so for hundreds of years in America
there were sodomy laws on the books and
then the American people were like
really we're not going to enforce this
stuff like this is none of our business
what people do behind closed doors and
then the laws were not enforced but on
the books and there were cultural
conservatives saying well you know those
laws they're important they should
remain just just to show that we don't
like this kind of activity and the
answer is that's not the role of
government if you don't like that
activity good news you got a church
right you should go talk about that a
church right good news you can say that
in the public sphere that it's bad for
people to engage in this sort of
activity that you don't like but it is
not the role of government to set out
the Ten Commandments that one's for God
all right so it's not the role and I
don't mean like the government to post
the Ten Commandments in a public place
the government can do that what I mean
is that the government is not your moral
teacher and as a religious person if you
believe that the government is your
moral teacher I wonder about the status
of your actual religious belief I don't
trust the government to be my moral
teacher you think a lot of Barack Obama
as my moral teacher shining rainbow
lights on the White House like he's not
my moral teacher
Donald Trump isn't my moral teacher
right I have moral teachers they're my
parents they are my my rabbis they are
there are many many non-jewish moral
teachers in a variety of areas but I
don't get my moral teachings from
government simply because they can point
a gun at me so there's this common good
conservatism that says that the
government is there to teach you I do
not think that the government is there
to teach you and in fact I think that
that has been mainly used by the left in
order to cram down their own particular
view of social policy I think it's quite
dangerous to create a tool in the
government where you give the government
the power to do that do you think
they're gonna own that forever it like
there's this weird divide among people
on the right where they're like well
this is the last election that ever
matters it's flight 93 election right
this is the last election it doesn't
after this if we don't win it's all over
and at the same time no we're in the
upswing where we own the we own the
means of government now let's cram
through our viewpoint well which is it
is this your last chance ever and if it
is your last
ever then do you really believe that you
promoting the quote/unquote common good
your version of the common good but
that's gonna last for five minutes
beyond your term the problem with
eternal moral principle is that it has
to remain eternal and the problem is
once you tie it to running the
government in other words only the
government can instill moral principle
that's that it's not in the cultural
realm we should put our work it's in the
governmental realm once it's only
government that can instill moral
principle well then as soon as the bad
guys take over government your job here
is done right you got nothing more to
say you've lost the answer is that if
you actually want a serious culture
shift in America you have to make it a
culture shift it can't just be a
government shift and this is why you
want local governments to reflect local
circumstance totally agree you want the
federal government to get in the
business of promoting the quote/unquote
common good good luck with that not only
good luck with it on a pragmatic level
it ain't gonna work on a moral level
you're gonna end up with a federal
government promoting policies that the
vast majority of the American people
don't like and then back to the
pragmatic level you are also going to
end the moral level you're gonna be
expanding the ability of government to
crack down on morality so that when
people you don't like take over they can
now point that government gun at you and
they can do it not just in the realm of
social policy they can also do it in the
realm of free speech they can do it in
the realm of they can do it in the realm
of economics as well now in a second I
want to talk about the realms of free
speech and economics because again I
think that you're seeing conservatives
take certain things they don't like and
basically say there's no right to do
that not recognizing that again you're
growing there's only one gun and we're
fighting over it okay so if the gun is
bigger and it can do more damage just
recognize that the bigger you grow that
gun it's gonna be turned against you in
the next moment like really in one
minute we're gonna get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
greatest gift you can get your lady for
Christmas or Hanukkah okay and how do I
know this because I'm married dr.
Shapiro a lot of people ask how can dr.
Shapiro stand you and the answer is I
buy her jewelry where do I get that
truly I get it from the pearl source at
the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry and up to 70% off
retail prices why because the pearl
source cuts out the middleman they
eliminate traditional five-times markups
by jewelry stores they sell directly to
you the consumer if you need it quickly
for the holidays it is not too late the
pearl source offers free two-day
shipping on every order everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it is ready to be given
as a gift and you will receive your
beautiful pearls well before it is time
to give them the pearl source comes with
a no hassle 60-day money-back guarantee
so it is also risk-free plus with more
than 20 years in the pearl business and
over 5000 five-star reviews you can be
sure that you are shopping from a
trusted retailer also you know you're
shopping from a great retailer because I
know the people who run the place I've
known them for 20 years they are
amazingly honest people they're gonna
get the best deals on the best jewelry
and the stuff is stuff you can hand down
to your kids it stands the test of time
it really is amazing go to the pearl
source right now save up to 70% off of
retail prices you can shop for everyone
on that christmas left wife mom sister
daughter it's a gift that does last time
and again you can hand it down the Pearl
source calm / been enter promo code
event and you get 20% off your entire
order so they're already 70% off retail
prices and you get an additional 20% off
when you go to the Pearl source calm
/ban I really cannot recognize recommend
them highly enough the Pearl source calm
/ ban enter promo club and my wife has
earrings from them she has a necklace
from them just beautiful beautiful stuff
the pearl source calm / been enter promo
code been at checkout goes straight to
the source the pearl source okay so why
does this debate matter this debate
matters because it's actually broader
than just the pornography debate
obviously when it gets to the realm of
economics it becomes the clearest but it
is also true in the realm of free speech
so we've had this big debate that's
broken out on the right / so-called drag
queens story our right drag queens
reading to kids of libraries egregious
stuff right just posit possibly child
abuse I mean I would argue likely child
abuse bringing your kid in front of a
sexualized cross-dressing adult to teach
them about children's books and
confusing them it's just a moral evil a
tremendous moral evil and what you've
seen is a lot of conservatives be like
well libertarians are fine with drag
queens story our well know the question
is how do you how do you propose to
achieve a regulation of things like drag
queen story hour without giving them
power to the library to determine what
is and is not allowed and if you give
that power to the library what makes you
think
that the library is not going to first
ban Bible hour before they ban drag
queen story our given the prevailing
winds of our culture it was pretty
obvious that the first people who are
getting at banned from the library are
cultural conservatives not drag queens
story our already seeing this in Canada
you've seen this in Seattle the big
story yesterday out of Seattle where a
feminist group that wanted to do an
event on why women are different from
men was nearly ban it's right now under
consideration being banned from the
public library there so once you give
power to an institution understand that
that power can be used against you it's
Lord of the Rings here okay that ring
that you think is going to defend you
against Sauron eventually is going to
corrupt you and you and it can be used
by sat around again retaining it allows
Sauron to regain the ring the more
powerful the ring the worse it's gonna
be when somebody you don't like gets
ahold of that ring and then you get to
the area of things like hate speech
really in the end what this comes down
to is do you have a right to do wrong do
you have a right to do things that are
morally wrong now on the local level you
can say well not as much as on the
federal level right because we all have
to live in a community together and
because we all generally agree and also
if you and I disagree on the nature of
right and wrong in a local community
then you can take off right you can you
can leave and mobility is a predicate to
this what's amazing is that many of the
same conservatives who argue that mobile
a mobility means that you should be able
to more heavily regulate at the local
level an argument with which I agree
will also say that people do not have
the ability to move from their home town
when the factory shuts down so that's
ideologically inconsistent but if you
are making the argument and that the
that when it comes to free speech for
example you have a you have no right to
do wrong now you're in the realm of the
hate speech left so if you're saying
that drag queens story hour should be
banned because you believe that drag
queens story hour is damaging to
children and you're not making the case
right you're not you're not bringing a
sociological case ii literally based
case you're basically just saying I
don't like drag queens and therefore a
drag queens story our is ban okay and
you're doing that at the federal level
let's say that you promote that policy
do you really believe that the
government getting involved in cracking
down on what is effectively political
speech is going to end well for you
you're thinking that's a good idea so
the founders did did believe in this
idea of right
why because the right was against
government it wasn't against your fellow
human being it was it was really against
government right your rights so-called
negative rights our rights that exist
before prior to anyone else right your
right to life means that I can't kill
you but really it's my right to life
right I'm not it's not an imposition on
you that you don't get to kill me
I'm saying you don't get to interfere
with me which is that's a negative right
the right to Liberty the right to
economic Liberty you do not get to
interfere with my consensual
transactions right those are individual
rights now I can misuse those I can be
bad I can do things that are immoral bad
for myself
I can do things that damage me but
that's my prerogative in a regime of
Rights because what is the other choice
the other choice is the idea of this
high-handed government that is going to
dictate to you what is best changing the
fundamental nature of man changing his
behavior from top down
well what monarchies have showed him for
several thousand years is that let's say
best of all possible worlds you get a
King David two generations later you get
a bunch of bad Kings and things suck hey
the fact is that monarchy is a bad
system aristocracy is a bad system rule
from above is a bad system and at the
same time you don't want a full-on
democracy because de Majorca you can
have dictatorship of the mob and that's
why the founders constructed exactly the
system checks and balances the
prevention of dictators of the mob or
dictators from above and encroaching on
fundamental individual rights but once
you get to common good conservatism you
actually end up in the realm of French
Revolution views of Rights rather than
American Revolution views of Rights the
French Revolution view of Rights is that
yes you have individual rights but in
the end the common good Trump's in the
end the common good can run roughshod
over those the American view of
individual rights is that those rights
pre-exists government and you have the
right to do wrong but they are also
connected with the social fabric and a
duty so we've done a fairly good job in
America of quote/unquote retaining the
rights but increasingly we've been using
the rights to do wrong increasingly
we've been using the right to free
speech to engage in pornography right
we've been using the right to do wrong
and increasingly we have been engaging
in the right to personal activity to
engage in drug use
we've been engaging in the right to to
sexual freedom to to have kids out
right increasingly we've been using the
right to do wrong the answer is not to
abolish the right the answer is to
abolish the wrong through the force of
culture this is where church always
mattered this is where social fabric
always mattered so if you wish to retain
economic freedom and freedom of speech
you have to recognize those things can
be used to do wrong but you also have to
recognize that the greater evil is
abolishing the right and that using the
government in order to re-instill a
sense of duty by quashing the right
itself is a very very large-scale
mistake because again that that
government can be used against you just
as easily as you wish to use the
government against others okay so I
think it's a really fascinating debate
well get to impeachment now gets it the
news of the day but I think that this is
again the consequences are very big for
economics they are very big for that
they are very big for free speech
they're very good for it for a lot of
these things right and again the idea of
government is teacher like that the
lines that are being used with regard to
government as teacher the law as moral
teacher a little scary john schweppe the
director of government affairs the
american principles project says quote
we believe that the law is a teacher and
in one of the examples they that people
who say this site is the Civil Rights
Act they said well the Civil Rights Act
said racism was wrong until racism
declined no there was a movement against
racism that led to the rise of the Civil
Rights Act it didn't arise in a vacuum
and that this is one of the great lives
of American government is that the
Supreme Court dictates from above what
morality is even obergefell you know the
a decision that abolished the idea of
traditional marriage in America as the
sole form of marriage sponsored by
government even oberst phone which is an
awful awful decision did not actually
accelerate the process by very much and
it was the result of a broad cultural
movement in American thought it was not
just the result of the Supreme Court
declaring one day that they were going
to do X Y or Z tha that that really is
not an honest take on what happened
their culture does continue to precede
politics change the culture focus on
changing the culture and allowing you
and allowing yourself the freedom to do
that because again as government expands
your freedom to change the culture is
going to contract this is what people on
the right need to understand the same
government you are using to crack down
on things you don't like is going to be
used first and foremost within
next ten years it's happened in
California it's already happened here
it's gonna be used to go after your
church your synagogue although all the
institutions that build the social
fabric family all of those will be the
first target not the last pornography
will not be the first target your church
will be the first target so be very wary
of growing that government gun okay
we'll get some impeachment in just one
second first let us talk about this
being of pornography have you seen I
hope you have not but there all these
stories about Scarlett Johansson's I
mean lavato people's headphones being
hacked and nudie photos being spray on
light so first rule do not take a nude
photo of yourself with your phone number
two it's super easy to be hacked and
celebrities get hacked all the time
hackers are constantly after your data
your credit card data your personal data
they can monetize it they can sell it
they can use it in order to steal money
from you why would you not protect your
data the answer is you should express a
VPN will help you do all of that you
might be thinking that security threats
don't affect you personally wrong way of
thinking about it everybody is is
vulnerable to data theft it's happened
to a huge number of people that I know
it will happen to you at some point in
all likelihood unless you protect your
data with express VPN so when you're
gonna do this just do it now visit my
special link right now and expressvpn
comm slash Ben get an extra three months
I've expressed VPN for free protect your
internet today with the VPN I trust to
keep my data safe go to express VPN calm
/ban to get started again that's
expressive VPN calm slash Ben to gets
started expressvpn the best way to
ensure that your your data is safe and
secure and also don't use your phone for
that guys I mean just don't but protect
your data expressvpn calm slash benefit
special deal three extra months before
free ok we're gonna get to all of the
news in a second exciting news first we
are hiring as one of the biggest
companies in conservative media daily
wire is growing fast looking for
talented people to join our team go
check out open positions over at daily
wire comm slash careers and apply today
applicants must be LA based or willing
to relocate if you're looking for an
awesome company culture full of amazing
people to work with look elsewhere but
then come here that's daily wire.com
slash careers go apply now and join us
you could be working with me tomorrow
and I could be reading zip recruiter ads
about how terrible you are the next day
daily we're calm slash careers and we
have some great news we have the perfect
gift for you to give this holiday season
it's the gift of a Daily wire membership
from now until January 1st all insider
plus gift memberships will be 25
percent off that means your loved ones
get all the phenomenal perks plus the
majestic leftist cheers tumbler and you
get the savings if you're not already a
subscriber you're really missing out
head on over to daily wire.com and
subscribe again that is 25% off all
insider plus gift memberships at this
holiday season give them a gift they
will thank you for all year long go to
daily wire.com slash gift and get your
25% off again that is daily wire comm
slash gift to get your 25% off
do not wait stop depriving yourself come
join the fun we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in America
all righty now to national politics
so the impeachment effort for the
Democrats continues to move forward the
the it really is quite boring to talk
about honestly because we all know where
this is headed we know that it's gonna
pass in the house we know that it's not
gonna pass in the Senate there is a
little bit of kickback in the house
you've seen some House Democrats
suggesting that they're going to defect
House Democrats are apparently bracing
for the possibility of defections from
moderates this is according to Rachel
bate and Mike de bonus over at the
Washington Post predictions about some
defections come as a core group of
centrist from districts Trump won in
2016 are apparently having second
thoughts while many new impeachment
would never be popular in their GOP
leaning districts some have been
surprised their support hasn't increased
despite negative testimony about Trump
from a series of blockbuster hearings
last month except they weren't
blockbuster and no one cares I'd say
that that's just silly
and though the fact is that the ball has
not moved anywhere in here and because
the ball has not moved anywhere in here
they're a bunch of moderates who are
saying well I'm not gonna put my name on
that dotted line that's not a thing that
I'm going to do and by the way nobody
also believes that the Democrats are
doing this more in sadness than in anger
people have the right idea they
understand that this is all a setup
they understand that Democrats do not
have the goods and are moving forward
anyway so in Jerry Nadler it's very it's
very tiring and irritating when Jerry
Nadler says things like with a heavy
heart I moved sure yeah your heart looks
you look very sad to have to do this
thing we have each taken an oath to
support and defend the Constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
I hope to be remembered for honoring
that oath I hope you feel the same and
so with a heavy heart but clear in my
duty to our country I support these
articles of impeachment to support them
as well look how much heaviness of heart
there is right there I mean he
apparently Brett keep from breaking into
with with the heaviest of hearts I feel
so set on the inside guys like really
upset so this is just not selling it's a
it's a dog that won't hunt the Democrats
do not have the goods Senate Republicans
are looking forward to a short trial I
think that in the end that's probably
the right move the senator the Senate
Republicans are saying why do we want to
delay this or prolong this it's not a
big win for Trump to have a long hearing
right instead let's just go where
everybody knows this is going to go move
on to the
20 elections and be done and that is the
direction that all of this is moving
meanwhile Democrats keep maintaining
that if Trump is not impeached that
Trump is going to steal the 2020
election which again is an
extraordinarily dangerous position
according to the Washington Post lawyers
for Congress meaning the Democrats urged
the Supreme Court on Wednesday not to
delay House committees access to
president Trump's financial records
saying the information could be crucial
to investigating foreign involvement in
American politics and legislative
protections for next year's elections
House General Counsel Douglass letter
said in a filing to the court
nothing is more urgent than efforts to
guard against foreign influence in our
systems for electing officials
particularly given the upcoming 20/20
election there's bipartisan agreement
that such interference is an imminent
threat so the Democrats continue to
maintain that if Trump is not impeach
then he might win and if he wins it's
going to be illegitimate so they're
already saying that the election is
illegitimate well in advance of the
election we all know what this is about
they don't think they can defeat Trump
at the ballot box right now or at least
they are very scared they cannot and
therefore they are pushing for it
impeachment that is why support is not
rising they have not made the case in
fact they've not really even attempted
to make the case okay in other news this
the it is amazing I predicted that the
Jersey City shooting that happened at a
kosher supermarket would be out of the
news in 48 hours
absolutely correct of course the media
don't care nobody cares
there is no widespread national
conversation about anti-semitism in
America there's no and there's no
widespread conversation about
anti-semitism among black Hebrew
Israelites or the the sad facts that
unfortunately anti-semitism is more
common among black Americans than it is
among general Americans I mean this has
been true in ADL polls going back twenty
or twenty thirty years there's there is
this serious strain of anti-semitism
that does exist in certain parts of
black America that ought to be talked
about in the same way that white
supremacism ought to be talked about I
mean the fact is that Jews who are being
beaten on the streets of Williamsburg
are largely being beaten by by people of
minority origin that is not connecting
race to the hatred of Jews it is saying
there are sub sections of culture in the
black community that really are rooted
in anti-semitism and that includes
people who are associating with Louis
Farrakhan and includes people who
associate with Jeremiah Wright it was a
blatant anti-semites at an
systematically
from the pulpit and Barack Obama Santha
for 20 years 20 years anti-semitism is
not foreign to many parts of black
communities in places like Brooklyn
which again is why Jews are being beaten
on the streets like let's say for
example that I'm about to I'm about to
play you a video of some footage from
right outside this kosher supermarket
okay this is video by a group called
Americans against anti-semitism they
took this video directly outside the
supermarket where this hate crime took
place which was again performed by two
black Hebrew Israelites which is a
anti-jewish hate group that says that
Jews are fake Jews and that because Jews
are fake Jews they are the real Jews
really terrible stuff okay so there is
this video that was put out by Americans
against anti-semitism first of all you
can see this video here of these two
guys well it's actually a guy in a woman
literally just getting out of their car
deliberately targeting the kosher market
walking in with guns and starting to
shoot people and you can see people
rushing out but that's not the video I'm
talking about that's troubling okay the
video I'm talking about that's troubling
obviously it's a shooting video so
that's always troubling but the video
that's really troubling is people in the
aftermath right members of the local
black community who are who are spouting
open anti-semitism directly as the
shooting is taking place and now let's
say that there were shooting at a
historically black church by white
supremacists and then there were a video
they came out within a day of white
members of the local community saying
those black people deserved it
that would prompt a widespread national
conversation about the extent of racism
I mean shooting alone does but but if
there'd been an additional tape of
people white members of the local
community talking about that in glowing
terms about how the people deserve to be
shot that would be used as an indicia of
a serious racism prom in the United
States and probably it should right okay
well this video actually came out and no
one is covering it it's not appeared on
mainstream news nobody cares about it
why well because in the intersectional
hierarchy Jews do not rank so the
intersectional hierarchy suggests that
the more you are a member of my own
minority you are victimized by by
mainstream American society but Jews do
not count despite the fact that Jews are
by leaps and bounds the group most
likely to be targeted for hate crimes in
the United States like far more than
blacks
far more than Muslims not close Jews
don't count in the intersectional
hierarchy because they're
disproportionately wealthy successful
and educated and so they're considered
part of the quote unquote white
community by the intersectional
community and so it does not so if
somebody who's lower down on the
intersectional hierarchy if if black
people in Jersey City if there are some
black people in Jersey City who are
saying that Jews deserve to get shot
that is not newsworthy because that is a
more victimized group talking about a
less victimized group in the view of the
intersectional hierarchy again this
video is quite disturbing and quite
stunning and again has appeared nowhere
in mainstream media because the
mainstream media do not wish to
acknowledge that there is a serious
anti-semitism problem in parts of the
black community the New York Times said
openly this last November November 1st
2018 they had a piece where they said
well there's been this big spike in
anti-semitism in New York and it's
largely coming from minority communities
but we're not gonna talk about that it
openly says in the piece we won't talk
about it because there doesn't seem to
be the common threat of white supremacy
the New York Times has an editorial
today by the way that basically says the
same thing only one type of
anti-semitism matters here is the tape
that you won't see on the media
understand that you're frustrated that
would be to the shot said that's great
ok again imagine there was this video of
white Americans after the Charleston
South Carolina shooting imagine that
national news this happens in Jersey
City nothing nothing not a word anywhere
no one else gonna play this tape why
because obviously this runs counter to
leftist narratives that the only people
victimized in America are victimized by
white people in America victimized by
the white hierarchy that is not true
racial politics are more complicated
than that unfortunately anti-semitism
spans lines the New York Times doesn't
care though like the New York Times has
an entire piece today in which they
condemn not anti-semitism with regard to
the Jersey City shooting but Trump's
executive order that he just promulgated
in order to crack down on anti-semitism
on campuses they come
against the executive order not on free
speech grounds you want to come out
against to the executive order on free
speech grounds first of all the
executive order itself says where this
conflicts with the First Amendment it
doesn't apply but second of all I don't
see any of these people saying that
title six of the Civil Rights Act which
deals with college campuses having their
federal funds withdrawn if there's
discrimination on campus against
protected groups I don't see any of
these people saying well isn't that
violative of the First Amendment the
entire title six you want to make that
libertarian argument I'm actually kind
of sympathetic to that libertarian
argument but that's not the argument
anybody's making they're just saying it
shouldn't apply to Jews and the New York
Times it basically says the same thing
they have an entire editorial today a
long editorial called the Trump's
executive order and the rise of
anti-semitism the president's campus
intervention ignores the bigger threat
of anti-semitism and threatens speech so
what in fact is the bigger threat of
anti-semitism than anti-semitism on
college campuses or anti-semitism in
Jersey City or Jews being beaten on the
streets of New York according to the New
York Times wait for it wait white
supremacy always white supremacy only
one type of anti-semitism matters to the
New York Times now white supremacy is a
threat it is anti-semitic it is evil
I've sat her I've condemned it for full
episodes I've talked about the evils of
the alt-right that's how I've talked
about the evils of the white supremacist
movement I've talked about how they're
growing I've been personally threatened
by the white supremacist I'm 24/7
security because of the white
supremacist but to pretend that
anti-semitism is only coming from the
side of the aisle where it is convenient
for you means that you don't give a damn
about anti-semitism in the new york
times does not give a damn this New York
Times editorial is an absurdity they say
last year anti-semitic attacks killed
more Jews around the globe than in any
year in decades okay so first of all
when they say killed more Jews around
the globe than any are in decades they
do not at any point in this article talk
about Muslim anti-semitism in Europe
which is one of the reasons why Jews are
being murdered in Israel one of the
reasons why Jews are being murdered in
Europe probably the chief reason trees
are being murdered in both Israel and
Europe okay so in any case the New York
Times says anti-semitic attacks killed
more Jews around the globe than in any
year in decades and then they mentioned
tree of life and they talk about the the
German Jews being cautioned not to wear
skull caps or Stars of David on the
street and attackers killing Jewish
college students in California
Charleston Virginia rang out with cries
of Jews will not replace us one year
before when local residents turned up
for services at Charlottesville's
congregation
Israel they found men with
semi-automatic rifles at the synagogue
doors offering protection they didn't
know that they'd need name by the way
anti-semitism remains rife like I went
to a kosher restaurant yesterday and
right outside on the curb somebody had
spray-painted anti-semitic graffiti like
that it's it's a thing that happens okay
but it happens to come from a variety of
sources
the New York Times only cares about one
of those sources listen to this listen
to this shift it's amazing on Tuesday
two gunmen including one said to have
published anti-semitic posts and to have
been a follower of the black Hebrew
Israelite meant which is hostile to Jews
killed four people in a rampage in
Jersey City that appears to have
targeted a kosher market the tides of
anti-semitism continue to rise higher
and more government action is sorely
needed the Department of Homeland
Security's recent strategy shift to
focus on the growing threat of white
nationalist terrorism was an important
step on Wednesday presidents from
stepped in himself but he did as much to
stir the waters as he did to set it to
settle them why because he added Jews to
title six of the Civil Rights Act of 64
which by the way had been department of
education policy under Barack Obama as
well the New York Times recognizes
similar congressional legislation has
had bipartisan support previous
administrations have taken similar
actions to prevent hate and
discrimination but well mr. Trump's
action might seem like a gesture of real
concern it does little to target the
larger source of violent anti-semitism
okay and then they say that BDS on
campus is not anti-semitism BDS is that
Muslim anti-semitism on campus which is
extremely rife when I was attending UCLA
the Muslim Student Association had a
publication called Al Talib in which
they joked about making Osama bin Laden
editor-in-chief and handed and the MSA
would hand out publications openly
fundraising for front groups for
terrorist groups okay but I love this
here's the ship for the New York Times
reading such incidents are frightening
but but the larger threat to American
Jews goes beyond college students
sparring over Israeli policy violence
anti-semitism is being in foment in most
significantly by white nationalists in
the far-right in other words Trump
should not even pay attention to
anti-semitism on campus and the New York
Times should not pay attention to
anti-semitism in New York City that will
overtly ignore it they should only pay
attention to white supremacist
anti-semitism do I take these bastards
seriously on anti-semitism no I do not
because they obviously do not take
anti-semitism seriously it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous if you're only taking
out
semitism seriously she can bash one side
of the political aisle and falsely
lumping conservatives with the white
supremacist by the way then you are
doing decency wrong in the New York
Times is famously doing decency wrong
these days okay time for a quick thing
that I like and then a quick thing that
I hate so a quick thing that I like
today so I had the opportunity to go to
screening for the movie 1917 by Sam
Mendes it's coming out in January and
the movies terrific it's really really
good it's it's incredibly well directed
I mean the entire movie it was basically
following these two soldiers who are who
are designated to try to move through
german-held territory in World War one
up to a a British position where the
British commander thinks he's going to
charge the German lines he's under the
mistaken impression that the Germans
have actually withdrawn and the Germans
have not withdrawn and so these two guys
are tasked with telling them that they
shouldn't attack it's beautifully shot I
mean the direction of it is really great
is it's done in one basically one
continuous tracking shot for the entire
movie there's only one point where it
actually flashes too black the entire
film now they're playing some camera
tricks but it's pretty incredible the
cinematography is just spectacular and
the acting is quite good as well it's
based apparently on the experiences of
Sam Mendes his grandfather in World War
one here's a little bit of the trailer
you have a brother in the second
Battalion yes sir
is he your life and with your help I'd
like to keep it that way
but they're walking into a trap your
orders are to deliver a message for
calling off tomorrow morning's attack if
you don't we will lose 1600 men your
brother among them
it's a very intense film it's really
it's really well done and again I
recommend it you should go see it in
theaters when it comes out and it I have
to say it feels like the quality of
filmmaking has really improved this year
there there are a few really good movies
that came out Ford versus Ferrari which
you've heard me recommend on the show is
is really first-rate and so is this film
1917 looking forward to seeing a few
more of these sort of Oscar rated flicks
even if I didn't like the Irishman or a
marriage story okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so apparently the New
York Times editorial page when it's not
defending anti-semitism coming from
particular sources is also a place for
people to spill their feelings about
their childhood struggles with sexuality
it's amazing half of editorial pages on
the left wing are now dedicated to
people telling their personal stories
about coming to grips with their own
orientation and it's like why okay so
what so here's the example Jennifer
Finney Boylan who is a transgender woman
meaning a man who believes that his
woman has a piece in the New York Times
called Rudolph the queerest holiday
special
it gets better for misfit reindeer too
so now we are to believe that a holiday
special constructed in 1964 is actually
a secret decoded message about being gay
in America and so we have a long piece
about why rudolph the red near red-nosed
reindeer is an inspiration to gay kids
the world over I'm sure the
conservatives who love this old holiday
chestnut will be infuriated by this
suggestion that it is the queerest
holiday special ever not infuriated just
puzzled why you would think that a
holiday special constructed in 1964 is
about gay rights and also why I would
care how you interpret Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer ms like a trite a
trite entry from your journal diary in
your intersectional Theory class but
Jennifer Finney Boylan says if you watch
the show without understanding that its
central conflict is the way people who
are different are constantly shunned and
humiliated well I don't know what show
you're watching
well what if that's just a general
message that applies to anyone who's
ever been bullied I was viciously
bullied in high school
and nothing to a sexual orientation a
lot of kids are but apparently
everything is now about sexual
orientation conservatives seem to miss
the point of a lot of things having to
do with Christmas actually is it really
possible that anyone can watch or read
Charles Dickens is a Christmas carol
without understanding its fundamental
critique of capitalism well know that
like a Christmas carol is not really
about capitalism so much as it is about
the idea that capitalism doesn't solve
the problem of the need for charity
right again this goes back to the
fundamental point of the show which is
that free markets and liberty are
wondrous wondrous things but you also
have to have an underlying social fabric
in order to promote those things as for
Rudolf the whole movie feels his LGBTQ
friendly to me says Jennifer Finney
Boylan as any episode of queer I or
Steven universe or the l word well
except for the fact that Rudolf doesn't
you know like have sex with any of the
other male reindeer
so aside from that and the fact that
it's a children's special I am
particularly tired of the hijacking of
children's literature and children's
special in order promote political
viewpoints on sexual matters like it's a
piece of children's literature cut it
out and the left likes to play this game
a lot when it comes to TV so what they
will do is for example some members of
the LGBTQ community will start saying
that SpongeBob SquarePants is like a gay
metaphor and then people are like what
are you talking about it's ridiculous
like stop and they'll say aha you're
upset because we said you're upset by a
children's cartoon it's like well no
you're the ones who are hijacking a
children's cartoon to make a point about
your own sexual orientation like what
what are you what hey I remember this is
a big controversy in the early 90s when
some members of the LGBTQ community
we're suggesting that some of the
Teletubbies were gay and so Jerry
Falwell made a comment about well the
Teletubbies aren't gay and it's silly to
try and hijack children's characters and
left-wing ha ha troll do you troll how
about this how about you just leave the
children's literature alone especially
because you have a whole wing of
children's literature we've talked about
it on the show that is specifically
designed to promote these sexualized
viewpoints for children can't just leave
Rudolph alone like he's got enough
problems that you putting your your own
issues with sexual orientation on his
fragile on his fragile flying back hey
really
the whole article and it goes on and on
and on and on it's just come on come on
okay well we will be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content so hope to see you then
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow as
we conclude the week I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is produced by Rebecca Dodd
poets directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling
technical producer Austin Stephens
associate producer Colton Haas assistant
director pavel white house key edited by
adam psy events audio is mixed by Mike
Romina hair and makeup is by Jess well
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]